that's feeding you hello I'm Nadia and
I'm cute and we are currently stoned
AF so we're gonna take the can you see
the difference in these 13 sets of
doppelgangers which is Amy Adams
honestly this is tough
I'm going to say it's number two because
that's who I know that's definitely not
Amy Adams it's everyone are you sure
well you know I'm gonna say is hurt Amy
oh okay so number two is gender phishing
and there's another Fisher in here so
I'm wondering are they siblings probably
not is Lee
Meester Minka Kelly I don't know who
these people are we got a 50-50 chance
let's look at this thing going on and
see if we can know a red floral almost
see-through dress their name matches
with a little bit of risk risk who is it
Minka dad real risky this is okay let's
go ahead Minkus she's a risk taker
you're playing who wants to be a
millionaire you seen my phone ahead is
this Jessica Biel I'm gonna have to say
no way what's with the bangs no
exclamation point quick and easy no need
to debate that's not Jessica Biel Tobruk
oh that's carly rae jepsen I don't know
what she looks the same
oh hell yeah
that's right hey I just met you next
number is Tom Hardy who is this guy what
what is his name Edward Edward and that
his name is Logan is this Katy Perry or
Zooey Deschanel that's definite eighty
berry it's not you know the angle and
the microphone threw me off for a second
Plus feeding you which number is Bryce
Dallas Howard well I know her name's not
bright oh there we go number one oh wait
you said this is probably hard okay yeah
she looks like a Bryson Dallas how it's
gonna shoot you ahead but and then
she'll take you to dinner so I'm gonna
be honest with you I don't know either
of those women I know margot robbie in
this this is her right dinner that's
where of Shana trigger I didn't know
what but I officially have a crush man
as of right now like I probably knew it
subconsciously before but this
solidified it this is Margo Rob Lee and
if you know Jaime Pressly oh no all
right this is my club wait look at it
edit this as a gift okay whatever is
Amber Heard that's Jessica from Saved by
the Bell
and also the the stripper in showgirls
you know oh my god you just brought me
way back whoa
it's definitely not hurt she's in a
vision with me she's a spy she's kicking
ass it was her named him ScarJo we're
gonna go with number one it was Amber
Heard okay oh my god she look she's
afraid she's out which number is Nina
Dobrev so I actually used to watch
Vampire Diaries so I know that yes well
picky because I'm lost
okay she's gay on the CW that's why I
never watch the CW I think I saw a
Riverdale one time what are you doing
I just Mila Kunis or Sarah Hyland this
is honors you right Kunis we know her
- oh yeah oh my god same person right
is this Dax Shepard or Dax Shepard okay
well I know he plays on scrubs there's
something describes guy
yeah dad Shepard was not mr. Grubbs no
no okay so number two
yes Zac Efron what
that ain't no Zac Efron no his name is
Zack I swear his name is that okay let's
see
oh is that grab there you go we're doing
really good here we are
is this not a weak one I don't know I
don't even know this is cure in Italy
and I'll tell you why I'm in love with
her tell the camera which number is
Javier Bardem yeah we ought to take a
wild guess on this one it looks like
Javier's cousin the same one but is two
of many surprises oh you thought loose
this shirt is that's a hobby variable
who is the other guy is Jeffrey Dean
Morgan I've never and he's wearing a
Jeffrey Dean type of shirt oh that was
it is that it we got 12 hour 13
reprimand people say hi people don't
know what they're talking about
I mean like as far as in our Ines and I
read
yeah I'm still like super high like my
eyes are just like barely open
[Music]